vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que les
etats-unis sont très forts pour
instaurer la démocratie partout où il
met les pieds après avoir magnanimement
écarter les leaders dont la politique
économique notamment ne leur plaît pas
et fait triompher la liberté et les
droits de l'homme dans les pays choisis
ils peuvent alors commencer à faire des
affaires fructueuses
il ya du pétrole mais pays d'amérique du
sud en connaissent un rayon depuis peu
washington s'est mis à s'intéresser à
deux petits états en plein développement
le surinam et le guyana tous deux
proches voisins du venezuela
évidemment ainsi mike pompéo fait un
passage éclair à paramaribo et
georgetown les capitales des anciennes
colonies néerlandaises et britanniques
pour officiellement y célébrer le
triomphe de la démocratie
le chef de la diplomatie américaine
s'était montré critique sur l'action de
l'administration du président sortant
guyanais david granger lors des élection
très contestée au mois de mars et avait
plaidé également pour une transition
démocratique à paramaribo lors des
élections législatives du mois de mai
ils profitent donc d'un changement de
majorité dans les deux pays pour
effectuer une visite officielle
mike pompéo doit d'abord félicité le
nouveau président du surinam chandika
persad tantôt qui issu de l'opposition
est élu en juillet par le parlement pour
ensuite faire un échange de politesses
avec le nouveau chef d'état du guyana
irfan ali qui a battu le sortant david
grainger celui qui n'aimait pas trop ce
dernier après avoir contesté sa défaite
a fini par s'y résoudre notamment à la
suite de sanctions imposées par le chef
de la diplomatie américaine à des
membres de son gouvernement accusé de
saper la démocratie
les sanctions ça marche bien quand même
ces deux étapes marque le début d'une
tournée qui mènera pompéo également en
colombie et au brésil près de la
frontière vénézuélienne dans le cadre
d'une campagne pour dénoncer la
politique de nicolas maduro au venezuela
autant rentabiliser mais à part ça il
vient quand même pas juste pour faire
des poignées de main si et bien en 2015
le groupe pétrolier exxon mobil a
annoncé avoir trouvé l'une des plus gros
ce réserves mondiales de brut depuis des
années dans les eaux au large du guyana
le géant américain est aussi très
présent au surinam
ah bah voilà washington assuré que le
secrétaire d'état n'était pas en mission
de lobbying pour exxon mais qu'il
encouragerait les deux pays à faire
preuve de responsabilité dans la gestion
de cette aubaine financière
surtout que la chine fait également
preuve d'intérêt pour le surinam et le
guyana et qu'un est attiré par le bois
et les minerais de cette région et a
récemment invité les deux pays à
participer à son initiative d nouvelle
route de la soie projet pharaonique
d'infrastructures lancés en 2013 pour
s'assurer l'amitié des capitales aux
quatre coins de la planète
en gros on vient féliciter les
présidents qu'on a récemment placé et on
en profite pour tirer une balle en
caoutchouc dans les pieds de pékin mais
affaire s'annonce juteuse